you know strangest adaptations with
warhorse you've got another one coming
up with great expectations what can we
expect from that well gross rotations is
you know we have we haven't had a
classical movie version in 60 years so
it's it's it's about time we had another
and it's it's nice to do a movie where
we didn't have to get caught up in I
think so many period movies are boring
because actors you tend to get caught up
in the etiquette you tend to get kind of
constricted by it and two characters
saying that they love each other across
the room is often you know done this
very sort of and you are in the period
advocate you're saying I love you know
and it's all it did I feel like we made
a conscious decision not to have that I
mean you've only got to read
Shakespeare's make people fall Justin
violently in love nowadays as they did
you know hundreds of years ago and so
we've done it in a way that I think is
raw and visceral and the emotions are
very much on the surface and when they
break out it is violent and it's no
different than if you were doing a
modern piece yeah did you say there have
been a number of versions for over the
years although not a classical version
for a number of years but one of the
classics of course is a david lean one
isn't it with john mills and the lead
role what's it feels stepping into those
shoes well that was actually the last
classical movie adaptation and that was
in 1946 um I didn't I didn't I didn't I
didn't think about it at all because
it's you know it that we had David
Nicholls writing scripts and I think he
wrote as close to a thriller as you can
with this kind of movie I mean when the
book came out it was it was it was cool
you know people said it was a thriller
and I think we tried to get back to that
and it's a very different movie as is
everyone so you know I mean every
adaptation will be different and this
isn't I haven't gone and looked to other
people I pepin go oh yeah and I'd be
nice let's do that it's just that you
know it is all got to come from inside
you I guess which sounds terribly
pretentious third but yeah you know I
suede is and you're closing the London
Film Festival this year with that film
as well how does that feel um I feels to
feel you know it's it's it's a huge
honor I guess I mean the whole thing
surreal
the fact that it's coming out of cinema
let alone closing a film festival is
weird there and finally I just want to
ask you a little bit about them two of
the homes you've got coming coming up a
night in all Mexico and also the railway
man you've got coming up too haven't you
yeah yeah I mean obviously you know I've
only really just finished both those
movies a railway man is a story that I
felt an incredible responsibility in
doing it's about a torch victim father
has the Japanese on the Death Railway
during the Second World War and I spent
time with the real man that I'm playing
so therefore you feel that you feel a
certain sense of responsibility that you
maybe wouldn't do normally so I was you
know things like I mean I lost a lot of
a lot of weight for that movie and and
did thing you know things I would
normally do for a role so that's going
to be fascinating us with Colin Firth
and Nicole Kidman so I'll be very very
interesting how that turns out and the
other movie like Mexico which is which
is comedy and a bit lighter which is
nice and you know again to work with a
cinema legend you know Robert Duvall and
you know again it's it's a weird and
wacky script and it's you yeah it's good
it's fun it's it's it's very original
and that's that's what always draws me
to movies like that only hopes and
dreams for next projects um I mean I've
you know I'm always reading scripts live
there's a there's a real drought of good
scripts at the moment I think there's a
lot of regurgitation zuv stuff we've
seen again and again I've and finding a
good script is tough and when you do
find and you find that it's it's you
know it's it's a feeding frenzy you know
every actor kind of goes Oh finally it's
you know something something genuinely
good and a new and and so it's you know
I certainly say no to a lot more than I
say yes to but um you know there's some
there's some few very exciting projects
out there um I'd love to go and do some
theater in the next couple of years
again but yeah we'll see this there's
some there's some really exciting stuff
being made so yeah
you